fireworks are associated with
celebration but they originally stem
from a place of fear and folklore
in 200 bc some people in china believed
that a tribe of scary bigfoot-esque
mountain men lurked in the foothills
and the most logical way to ward off
this enemy scare them
they realized that heating bamboo shoots
caused air pockets in the plant to burst
creating a loud popping noise which they
thought would keep the mountain men away
and it allegedly worked
800 years later chinese muggles set out
on a quest for immortality and while
they didn't find the elixir of life
these alchemists ended up creating the
world's first batch of gunpowder funny
how the desire to live forever was
essentially a gateway drug to modern
warfare but anyway back to the story
they took this new fire drug as they
called it stuffed it into their bamboo
shoots and kaboom
fireworks were born
excitement over the invention of
gunpowder and fiery sticks eventually
made its way around the world
fast forward to july 3rd 1776 the day
before the declaration of independence
was signed john adams wrote a letter to
his wife with big plans for
commemorating the day it ought to be
solemnized with pomp and parade
bonfires and illuminations from this
time forward forevermore
adams wanted illuminations he got him
the sky lit up with fireworks on july
4th and from that day forward fireworks
have become a ubiquitous american
celebratory tradition
so i guess the next time you see the sky
ablaze you can thank bigfoot i mean the
chinese or john adams your call
you